Vùng với việc tổ chức đoàn đến tiếng và chia buồn với các gia đình nạn nhân trong vụ trái nghiêm trọng,
sẽ ra tại cư gia đất lập tối nề mừng sào tháng bệnh.
Cơ quan chức năng, chính quyền địa phương, các tổ chức đoàn thị tại thành phố Xí Minh đang hình chương lên phương án hỗ trợ các nạn nhân.
Mối hổ giết định có người tử vong trong vụ trái sẽ nhận được tổng cộng 1,5% đồng tiền hỗ trợ.
Trong đó, vì bán mà chẳng tổ quốc thành phố Xí Minh hỗ trợ 2,5% đồng một người.
Ui bán nhân dân phương hỗ trợ 3 mi trợ đồng một hộ, mà chẳng tổ quốc phương hỗ trợ 4 làm trợ đồng một người.
Ui bán nhân dân quận tổng, cú, hỗ trợ 5 trợ đồng một hộ.
Ngoài ra, giáo hội phật giáo quận tổng, cú, cú hỗ trợ 4 hộ 1 mi trợ đồng và tổ chức lễ cầu xưa các nạn nhân.
Mình cảnh công tác tham hỏi, hỗ trợ, Ui bán nhân dân phương phủ thỏ hoàn đã yêu cầu bán khoảng trị cư gia đất lập và các hộ dân khẩn trường thảo giữa bản bộ phần cười lối.
Sẽ giữa sai quy định nhằm đảm bảo an tòn phòng trái chữa trái và giữa dình Mỹ quán đồ thị.
Thơi hạn hoàn thành việc thảo giữa là trước ngày 1 mùi tháng bệnh.
Vềm viên nhân vụ trái, chung ngày 1 tháng bệnh, công an thành phố Chí Minh cho biết,
miên nhân bán đầu của vụ trái xe gia tại cư gia đất lập vào huyên ngày 1 sau tháng bệnh huyến tám người thiết mạng là gió chập định từ vệ thống dây đấu nối tự phát.
Cơ quan cảnh giá đều tria công an thành phố Chí Minh đang tích tục xử vụ việc theo quy định pháp lật.